j'ai 81 ans et près d'un milliard de
sujets je suis au pouvoir depuis 62 ans
le règne le plus long de l'histoire
avant nous fini messieurs karine vous
allez vous rendre en angleterre ou
servir et la reine mais en aucun cas
vous ne devez regarder sa majesté co
l'inde connaît de nouvelles famines et
l'irlande une nouvelle agitation et si
le premier ministre est terrible et
primat de la gelée
votre majesté je me sens soudain
revigoré
comment trouvez-vous nouvelle tenue
écossaise elles sont floues gueuse tout
air rugueux en écosse m
de quoi peuvent-ils bien parler qu est
ce qu une mangue varennes des fruits
j'aimerais une mort qu elle ne pousse
qu'on offre
je suis impératrice des indes comme on
en voit je croyais sa majesté mourante
nul ne sait vraiment ce qu'est être
reine
bertil mère m'espionner vous merci je me
sens ici
[Musique]
à quoi bon tout cela peut-il servir
votre majesté
j'aimerais cap dou le mas truies
le gym est odieux votre majesté je suis
la reine d'angleterre je recevrai tous
plaident que je réclame tu a bouleversé
toutes les règles mr vous porter
préjudice à la couronne 9e premier
ministre votre majesté vous à les
renvoyer ce paysan indien où nous vous
déclareront folle et vous feront
internet
[Musique]
je suis acariâtre avides cracheuses est
affreusement attaché au pouvoir mais je
suis tout sauf bon à enfermer
comment osez vous méprisez ap tout je
suis reine d'angleterre
je suis impératrice des indes mais plus
que tout je suis au service d'un
milliard de sujets abdul ne doit son
ascension qu'à son seul mérite
lui aussi était un serviteur à présent
il est mon ami
voilà des années que n'ait pas été aussi
heureuse un cadeau de l' empire des
indes question mangue
elle est gâtée sera riche cette mangue
et gâtés voyons
[Musique]